[Music]
foreign
and sort of coming together and and what
this all kind of meant for her and and
and and and what this has done for sort
of your relationship and your marriage
yeah so um yeah several different things
kind of occurred
um number one
I would say the biggest thing was
gratitude I was so
I didn't think I was going to make it
um
and I was so grateful to wake up and
still be alive
um I was elated
um it probably helped that uh I hadn't
really done uh uh drugs up to that point
in my life and uh
and man being high on super heavy
morning Dilaudid was pretty awesome
pretty awesome for sure
so
um but I remember I I came to and and
the first thing I remember is I tried to
talk and just air came out and the nurse
came over and was like hey lieutenant
you're not gonna be able to talk uh
you're you're trained and you're wired
shut
um so I was like okay give me something
to write with and uh my commanding
officer and uh command Ash Chief were
there and I wrote out three questions I
I said uh
are my guys okay and they said yes uh
you know Luke and Matt are out of
surgery they're good and I said okay uh
has my wife been notified my co said yes
uh I talked to her myself
um she's good you know they're
coordinating things she's going to meet
you in Bethesda when you get there
and then uh I don't know why I was like
do I still look pretty and they were
like no
they're like this will probably be an
improvement so so good little humor
um so I was in Baghdad they moved me to
balad which is where they treat head
injuries and I don't really remember a
lot about that I remember being in the
ICU at balad
um
and then they moved me to Landstuhl
Germany and uh it was in Germany that
they did some more stabilization
surgeries and I don't know if my my
teammate who flew with me was like hey
do you want to talk to your wife and I'm
like yes but I couldn't talk so I was
like hey I'll write down the questions
and you or write down and you relay
so we called my wife and uh and uh
I think the first thing I said was hey I
got all shot up but my Wang's okay which
you know I mean you know God forbid and
there are a lot of guys out there that
unfortunately got their uh you know
privates blown off or shot off so I am
very thankful and for those guys you
know and to the doctors out there
they're working on things like that but
it was a big deal and just go on to let
her know and he was so funny because
he's like you [__] serious yeah I
really got to say that I really got to
say this but I bet it made her you know
my guy's still my guy because that was
the thing she didn't know my mental
state
uh they didn't really know my my co when
he first called her was like you know
hey Jay's alive he's been shot in the
face but you know we don't we don't know
yet
so um
and then they loaded me on the plane to
fly home and I will tell you I developed
this uh probably the biggest fear I've
ever felt in my life was
um this
fear of how she was going to handle it
because
I I didn't see myself yet but I knew man
I mean I'm traked they're feeding me
through a stomach tube I mean I've got
you know I'm I'm too weak to move I've
got tubes coming out of everywhere you
know I'm on all this ICU equipment and
um I knew I had no nose I uh I felt like
a monster and I was really terrified of
how she was going to handle that how my
kids were going to handle that
and you know unfortunately good or bad
I'd read a lot of stories about war that
knew that you know when individuals get
wounded that's an immense strain on the
family and there are unfortunately a lot
of
spouses who say I didn't sign up for
this and there are stories of spouses
showing up at Walter Reed and Bethesda
naval hospital and like walking into a
room with a severely Wounded Warrior and
saying nope and taking rings off and
putting them on the table and leaving so
I developed this huge fear of this and
we had been married six years
um
but I was uh
I was afraid I was afraid at how she
would handle that and uh finally we
landed they took me up to my room in the
ICU
and uh uh the nurse was I don't know
taking care of me getting me situated
and um she's like she's like oh you
still have blood in your hair and I'm
like you have to clean me up like you
know it's like
I like what like dude you're like
totally blown to pieces like what the
[__] there's some blood in your hair
gonna make the difference but I don't
know in my mind like hey you have to
make me as presentable as possible for
my wife and and my wife at this point
was standing outside the door and uh
she's like your wife's outside and I'm
like I'm not ready
and um
you know finally she's like your wife's
still outside and I was like okay and I
was so afraid I expected her to come in
and like to be shocked to gasped
I don't know to not want to be close to
me
um
and uh
my wife is amazing because she man she
came in that room she locked eyes with
me she walked straight up and and pushed
the you know tubes out of the way and
kiss me on the lips
and I was like hey
we're gonna be okay we're gonna get
through this and like I I needed that uh
you know I'm
pretty mentally strong but to have
someone
like I needed that like I needed that uh
and man it became like this driving
power and it became
like man she earned her title the
long-haired Admiral at that point and
and so
from that point forward man she was like
my best nurse like I mean she man she
was like running that place like she had
a notebook and and it's overwhelming
when you're severely wounded you have
teams of doctors and teams of nurses and
there's so much information and man she
was tracking all of it
you know when they finally let me out of
the hospital after eight weeks and sent
me home I was still really messed up I'm
in a wheelchair I've got metal hardware
out of my body I'm still there they're
feeding me through a stomach tube I'm
tricked I'm still wired shut you know
all these stitches and all this [__]
and uh
and even though we had a home health
nurse that would come three times a week
to change dressings and all this she had
to do a lot of that she tricks are
disgusting I wore a trach for seven
months in two days it oozes mucus and
nastiness it gets clogged and it has to
be constantly cleaned and she did that
I was fed through a stomach tube so my
food had to be ground up my meds she had
to use a mortar and pestle to like grind
up my meds and put them in with my food
she never ever complained man never and
I know it had to enter her mind like you
know we had we had three small kids and
now you know you get this invalid
husband
who was living his dream to be at Navy
SEAL Warrior and now he comes home and
you know you're having to take care of
him and I know in her mind man
she said she didn't think it but I know
she had to I mean it's human you know
but man you talk about strong emotional
leadership I knew she had to think why
did you do this to us you know but she
never did man always positive always
supportive and uh
yeah so I owe so much to her
um I write a lot about that in my book
The Trident about how amazing she was
and and what an amazing team we are
um now we run our business together
we're actually hopefully signing a deal
on a relationship book because it's such
a big thing so many people ask us like
how did you do this
SEAL Teams have a 90 divorce rate when
the Warriors have like an 85 divorce
rate
um so we we have defied all these odds
and uh yeah so
she is the long-haired Admiral lha for
sure and uh
she's pretty amazing
[Music]
foreign
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world is
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and uh again grateful that you guys tune
in we've decided we want to take things
just a step further it's a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become a part of this
community look I already board Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]